today i'm gonna be memorizing all 898
pokey men growing up i wasn't allowed to
play with pokemon because my parents
thought it promoted violence today
though that leaves me out of a lot of
social situations because it seems like
everyone else's parents didn't care
about them people are always like tucker
you're an idiot for not knowing who
gorbhut is or you don't know who bing
slice is that's he's one of the best uh
lava types pokemon i hate you for not
knowing who dinglepuss is you don't know
alfredo the italian pokemon tucker you
always get the worst haircut
and i'm like okay sorry my parents cared
about me this week i have lunch with my
boss sylvie and i really want to impress
her because my job only lasts another
two months and i think i can if i play
my cards right or should i say my
pokemon cards right oh this is terrible
step one memorize all 898 pokemon in 48
hours step two impress my boss step 3
don't have to go back to my old job now
i'm gonna list all the pokemon that i
actually know pikachu raichu squirtle
blastoise wartortle charizard charmander
mewtwo dig diggler is that one no okay
duran is that one i'll count that as one
jigglypuff obviously snorlax
okay so now i only have to memorize 883.
okay i feel really confident about this
growing up i feel like i had a really
good memory ever since i've been an
adult i haven't been as good at it
probably because of some extracurricular
lifestyle choices in which you know
parts of my memory haven't been taken
care of also
changes on the way
you're gonna move up and do your stuff
till graduation day
old school middle school it's a
different year so much to know before
you go i have to say it seems like
sometimes the people who name them
pokemon are pretty lazy like for example
the seal is named seal i think for that
one too they were just like okay that
one's named seal we gotta make the next
one not have anything to do with seals
at all let's name it dugong my favorite
one maybe so far doug trio it's just
three things that dig tend to cool to
tend to cruel kind of like
[Music]
certain people that have dated 150 total
that means we're actually 25 of the way
done i'm worried that i'm just starting
to get kind of brain overload so i'm
gonna take a break now just so i can
clear my mind a little bit
okay
so i just went and bragged that i was 25
done like i just told you guys and they
were like
someone said i'm less than 20 done it's
not going as well as i thought
typhlosion chikorita bay leaf megani
this is one of the most difficult things
that i've had to do like i memorized all
these pokemon and then i look up and i
don't recognize any of them and i'm like
oh okay great doing super well i have to
memorize 700 more and i'm not sure i got
the first 200 totally down pat anyway
some of these i will say are feeling
like they are coming into my brain and
then immediately leaving my brain
officially at 300 i'm feeling good i'm
gonna take the test and see if i can
name first 300 pokemon and we'll go from
there i'm nervous but uh let's see how
it goes
okay bulbasaur ivysaur venusaur
charmander charmeleon charizard clefairy
yeah
diggle i remember this vapor head
vileplume it's called forget about it no
what's it what's up pig guy
prime ape oh cause not a pig it's monkey
all right so
this many wrong
only 176 correct quite bad
i'm feeling hopeful but i am feeling a
little more defeated than i was at the
beginning of the day i feel really
confident about this you're really
confident about this oh this is horrible
but say right now i'm feeling
probably like
60 confident i think i can still do it
back day two i made these cards and
these cards have a little tiny
description of every single pokemon
milotic which is just a great haired
snake zangoose has two claws on each
hand and then also looks like he's in a
production of cats torkol is my favorite
uh because he is a turtle that vapes i
think i got a lot of these now i'm gonna
try a couple more techniques also
including drawing switching up study
spots and then also my emergency break i
stole from my roommate this bottle of
alpha brain he takes it all the time
there's uh you know tyrosine elfiani
bacopa
feel like i'm memorizing the pokemon
the clock strikes 8 pm the night before
our hero's deadline he still hasn't
studied 250 pokemon
burnout has set in
morale is low when i was a kid
i wasn't
cool
right i was i was smart though i was
good at memorizing stuff so
it's really bumming me out that i'm
having trouble memorizing all these
because it makes me feel like my brain
isn't as
um
like sharp i guess as it was when i was
a kid which sucks coming up against my
own ego where it's like
well maybe you can't do this like maybe
you're not as smart as you think i feel
like this buzzfeed fellowship is one of
those opportunities where i'm getting to
do what i want to and i feel like you
know i'm not going to have um a job in
two months basically
i think it's time i call my most
positive friend
hello
hey what's up man
how can i help you starting to feel like
this might have been uh you know i might
have bitten off more than i can chew let
me stop you right there you can do this
you're undercutting your own abilities
here
dig into that that part of your soul
that wants that needs to know these
pokemon
and i think you're capable of that i
know you're capable of that i'm rooting
for you because i i believe that you can
do this and you need to believe that you
can do this
like chris said i just need to tap into
the part of myself
that really needs to know these pokemon
kids all over the country today probably
know every single pokemon so i can do
this
oh yeah
bad news alert while i'm doing this i
checked my phone and there are 10 new
pokemon that got released this morning
how are there new pokemon coming out
like
while i'm doing this just going to add
them to the list and keep grinding
all right so we've come to the end it's
time to do the final test i came from
being a guy who knew 15 pokemon to now
trying to see if i can get 908
so let's get to it baby
it's already been 20 minutes
so it's gonna take me three hours to do
this quiz i have to hurry up i mean
obviously i would prefer to catch them
all but
i think at this point if i got 500 i'd
be ecstatic i can't tell how it's going
anymore because uh they're starting to
blend together
it's just got now just got just got
guesses
oh god okay before i click
check answers proud of myself for what i
did i put in a lot of work and no matter
what these results are this was fun to
do
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god i got it took me 125 minutes
to take this quiz and i got 812 out of
908.
oh my
god i'm so happy beyond expectation i
think of where i thought i was when i
woke up at 5 20 this morning
let's let's go talk to sylvia i don't
have time i have to go talk to sylvie
okay
she's coming in now
you like pokemon right well i actually
memorized all of them i can tell you all
of them now bulbasaur charmander
firo
golduck
he's like a tortoise that vapes
and finally two cannon i think i got all
pretty much all of them yeah
great good job that was awesome yeah
thanks
um you're impressed right
i'm definitely impressed that was very
cool yeah yeah do you think maybe this
could you're so impressed that you would
extend my fellowship past
the end date oh i don't know if it was
like so cool it's more about like if the
video does well but yeah but you are
doing this was a great job oh
oh thanks yeah i threw into a meeting
but good luck
one more
um cool
all right see ya
well i guess it's up to you guys if this
video does well then i get to keep my
job
[Music]
congratulations
well done
well done
congratulations to you